[Music]
hello and welcome to 3abn today Bible
Q&A okay I have a question what do you
do when you have a question well you can
send it in to 3abn today Bible Q&A hello
my name is Angela lomacang I'm glad that
you've tuned in today to this worldwide
Ministry thank you for your prayers and
support of this ministry it is greatly
appreciated
well we have a wonderful panel today and
let me just introduce the panel okay we
have a great panel let me start with the
man in front of me okay the man in front
of me my husband Pastor John lomma Kang
welcome honey always glad when you're on
the program and I want to thank those of
you who are tuning in today it's always
a blessing to see what you have to come
up with what kind of question and we
never know what it's going to be but it
always challenges us so thank you for
that yes all right and next to you
Pastor Daniel Marone welcome thank you
so much and thank you for sending in
those really interesting questions we
got some good ones today thank you how
long have you been pastoring I'm retired
20 years I pastored oh my that's a long
time yeah okay next to me is Daniel
parin welcome Daniel thank you very much
it's good to be here and there are great
questions and I'm looking forward to
this program now you work in pastoral
Ministry I'm sure you get a lot of
questions there yes we do I mean lots of
people to pray with and and then Bible
questions that don't give any
preparation time you just oh you got to
go with it right in the right you're
right let the Holy Spirit help you yes
yes well thank you we have a wonderful
panel as I mentioned and if you have a
question okay you may say oh I have a
Bible question that I really want an
answer for and truly we go to the word
of God for our answers cuz that's that
this is our guide book right here okay
now say if you want to uh call us you
can call call us by going calling us at
or texting us at 618 228
3975 or you can email us at bible QA
3abn and I believe we have Instagram
which is 3abn uncore official okay
Instagram at
3abn official but before we go on Daniel
would you offer a word of prayer for us
please yes let's pray our loving
Heavenly Father Lord we are full of
questions because we don't have the
knowledge and the answers in ourselves
so we go to your word and you've given
us the Bible you've given us the Holy
Spirit to understand not only understand
but to put it into practice so I pray
for those of us here in the studio I
pray for those who are listening and
watching that you would guide and direct
their lives through your Holy Spirit and
through your word in jesus' name amen
amen thank you now most of the questions
are three minute questions and we have
all of them except for one we have each
panelist have four questions and one of
the question is that will'll answer is a
four minute question so basically
there's three minutes and we're going to
start in front of me with my husband
John lomacang we're going to give you
your first thre minute question and here
we go I did not raise my daughter to
know about Jesus and I did not take her
to church
but I love my daughter very much and I
still do I lost her when she was 32
years old she was not living the way she
should have been am I accountable for
her death and this is from
Angela you know first of all I know
whenever a mother loses a child and
we've been confronted with that um so
many people are wondering what could I
have done differently and that's not a
question that you're alone are
struggling with but let me just go and
tell you that um when your daughter
reaches a certain age the
accountability becomes hers uh we could
only be accountable for things that
happen when they are minors you know the
Bible does say train up a child in the
way they should go and when they are old
they will not depart from it but if you
have chosen not to do that the child now
confronts a decision that they have to
make for example James
4:17 it says therefore to him who knows
to do good and does not do do it to him
it is sin well we have this nature that
we receive when we come into the world
it's a broken Fallen nature and we're
given the opportunity the Bible says as
many as received him to them he gave
power or the right to become children of
God so you don't know what your daughter
did in the private moments of her life
you don't understand what her decisions
have may may have been about her her
walk with the Lord or calling on the
Lord in the closing moments of her life
those are things that I believe you need
to leave in the hand of the Lord rather
than saying Lord what's going to happen
to my daughter I did not do what I
should have done that's that's what your
position is and that's why you're
feeling that way but there are certain
scriptures in the Bible that makes it
clear uh Ezekiel 18:20 it says the son
or the daughter shall not bear the guilt
of the father nor the mother nor the
father bear the guilt of the son the
righteousness of the righteous shall be
upon him and the wickedness of the
wicked shall be upon himself so each
person has to give an account 2
Corinthians 5:10 for we must all appear
before the Judgment seat of Christ that
each one may receive the things done in
the body according to what he has done
whether good or whether bad so that's
personal accountability and that's why I
encourage people uh I was talking to a
group of young people just recently and
I said when you think about your life
and the way it's going to end because
everyone's life is going to end one way
or the other whether we are wealthy or
whether we are poor whether we have
great possessions or none at all we are
all coming to this inevitable end that's
just the way of life the wages of sin is
death but because of Jesus that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life and
then finally there are two resurrections
and these resurrections determine the
decisions we made when we were alive do
not Marvel at this John 5:28 for the
hour is coming in which all who are in
the graves will hear his voice and will
come forth in verse 29 those who have
done good to to the resurrection of Life
those who have done evil to the
resurrection of uh condemnation so
Angela let me encourage you this way
don't try to figure out the destiny of
your daughter leave that in the hand of
the Lord say Lord whatever thy will is
let thy will be done and know that the
Lord will not hold you guilty for her
decisions amen that's so true and I too
well my sister has lost her son only 43
years old so it is difficult to lose a
child so yeah just continue to trust in
the Lord he's not willing that any
should perish remember that he'll do
everything he can to save you he'll do
whatever it takes thank you honey all
right let's go to Daniel Marone this is
a 4minute question here we go the word
tells us that no one can see God and
live if he walked with Adam and Eve in
the cool of the day then they must have
have seen him they were made in His
image when they sinned their eyes were
opened did Adam and Eve see God this is
for Mary in
Tennessee great question Mary thank you
so much for sending that
in you know you're correct in U
recognizing there was a change in the
relationship between God and man before
and after sin in Exodus 33:30 the Bible
says thou c not see my face for there
shall no man see me and live this was
God speaking to Moses who wanted to see
God's
glory let's look at the scripture that
you were referencing in Genesis 2:25 it
says and they were both naked the man
and his wife and they were not ashamed
then in chapter 3:7 right after they ate
of the forbidden fruit it says and the
eyes of them both were opened and they
knew that they were naked and they sewed
fig leaves together and made themselves
aprons so we see that shame came in
after they disobeyed god let's continue
the story in verses 8- 11 and they heard
the voice of the Lord God Walking In The
Garden in the cool of the day and Adam
and his wife hid themselves from the
presence of the Lord God amongst the
Trees of the garden and the Lord God
called unto Adam and said unto him where
art thou and he said I heard thy voice
in the garden and I was afraid because I
was naked and I hid myself and he God
said who told thee that thou was naked
notice God didn't give Adam a chance to
say anything so we can presume that the
next words that God speaks is the answer
to why Adam was naked and felt shame
hast thou eaten of the tree whereof I
commanded thee that thou should us not
eat so here's where guilt or shame came
into mankind the Bible calls it sin when
we go against God's word or command 1
John 3:4 whosoever committeth sin
transgresseth also the law for sin is
the transgression of the law or the
commands of God and that's where we get
the feeling of wanting to hide from God
the Bible says in Romans 3:23 for all
have sinned and come short of the glory
of God so prior to Adam's sinning he
hadn't come short of the glory of God I
believe that he was clothed with God's
glory and that uh that's why they were
naked and unashamed when Adam was filled
with the glory of the God he was able to
reflect God's glory Glory rather than
being consumed by it when the Bible
speaks of God's glory it's actually also
speaking of his character they're
synonymous uh going back to Exodus 33:18
and 19 Moses says I beseech thee show me
thy glory and God answers back in verse
19 I will make all my goodness pass
before thee I'll proclaim the name of
the Lord before thee I'll be gracious to
whom I will be gracious and I'll show
Mercy on whom I will show mercy so when
Moses asked to see God's glory god said
that he would show it to him by
proclaiming his goodness or his
character what kind of God he is he's
good when Moses came down from Mount Si
being after being with God his face
glowed and we can read about it here in
Exodus 34:30 and when Aaron and all the
children of Israel saw Moses behold the
skin of his face Shone and they were
afraid to come nigh unto him this was
after Moses had seen the back of God
from the crevice of Rock So after sin
mankind was not has not been able to
take in the fullness of God's glory but
the Gospel of Jesus Christ which is that
he Jesus Took My penalty for sin and
suffered the wrath of God in my place so
that I can be changed into His Image or
glory and this happens as we look Upon
Jesus he said in John 12:32 and I if I
be lifted up will draw all men unto me
by looking unto Jesus our characters are
changed and friends I I'll leave with
you with this admonition from Paul in 2
Corinthians 3:18 but we all with open
face beholding as in a glass the glory
of the Lord are changed into the same
image from glory to glory even as by the
spirit of the Lord and wow praise the
Lord we're looking forward to that thank
you again for that question amen thank
you and aren't we told that Jesus did
the talking he spoke through he's Jesus
did the speaking didn't he he's the one
that God used that's right God the
father right right yeah thank you all
right Daniel here's your question are
you ready here we go if I go back to my
old sin will God intervene and still
want me if I Repent this is from berest
in Georgia berest I want to thank you
for texting that question to us because
sometimes we wonder could God ever love
someone like me
after what I've done and the good news
is God does Love Someone Like You God
loves you Angie just referred to a text
in 2 Peter 3:9 that says God is not
willing that any should perish he wants
you and God does intervene the Good
Shepherd always goes after the Lost
Sheep amen Jesus intervened by coming
down to this earth and giving his life
for you you're too valuable we're too
valuable to give up on now and God
intervenes by sending the Holy Spirit to
prompt us to repentance I want to share
with you a text in the book of Hosea
chapter 14 verses 1 to3 describes uh God
longing for Israel to return to him in
heartfelt repentance and then in verse
four of chapter 14 it says I will heal
their backsliding I will love them
freely for my anger has turned away from
him you can find a very similar promise
in Jeremiah 3:22
when Israel repents of their backsliding
God freely forgives we find this in the
New Testament too in Ephesians chapter
4:32 we are told to be kind and
tender-hearted to one another and
forgive one another even as God in
Christ Jesus has forgiven you so when
the disciples wanted to ask about this
pattern of of forgiveness that we
supposed to follow what does God forgive
like they thought that it would be
sufficient to forgive somebody seven
times that's a lot and Jesus using
Heaven's exponents goes above and beyond
and says you're not even close but
forgive 70 times seven that's in Matthew
18:22 in other words God's pattern is to
forgive the repentant Sinner and he
passes that pattern on to us to follow
now this is not freedom for us to then
sin willfully because ah God's going to
forgive me no that's a willful and uh
and presumptuous sin CU we don't know if
we're going to have a chance to repent
or if we would even take it we simply
should repent and follow God's prompting
of his spirit with the breath that we
have right now I want you to know this
God does not want you to go back to your
old life of sin and he has given us
every power of His grace possible to
make that a reality in your life read
these texts here's two and I'll get
there's many more Philippians 4:13 says
I can do all things through Christ who
strengthens me and that promises victory
over sin through Christ power Romans
8:37 says says in all these things we
are more than conquerors through him Who
Loved Us Praise the Lord he gives us the
power to be victorious then hold on to
these two promises in 1 John 1:9 and
then 1 John 2:1 if we confess our sins
he is faithful and just to forgive us
our sins and to cleanse us of all
unrighteousness go look up 1 John
chapter 2 verse one on your own wow that
was powerful act and God Is So merciful
he's so kind he wants you in the Kingdom
he's doing all that he can to get you
there amen he gave God gave his son
Jesus that's the greatest sacrifice
thank you all right John omang here's
your question straight to the
point can you please explain Mark 8
verse
34-35 and John 12 25-26
six sure let's Dive Right In I'll read
the two passages for you starting with
Mark 8:34 and 35 when he had called the
people to himself with his disciples
also he said to them whoever desires to
come after me let him deny himself and
take up his cross and follow me verse 35
of Mark 8 for whoever desires to save
his life will lose it but whoever loses
his life for my sake and the gospels
will save it you know denial of self is
the Apex of serving God there are those
who say I want to serve God but I'm not
willing to get rid of my way of life I
want to serve God on my conditions and
that's what is being talked about here
the Lord says if anyone would follow me
let him deny himself you know that
denial of self is the greatest battle
you'll ever face of saying no to
yourself when through your life of
habits and practices and and and and um
acquiescing to wrong ideas and wrong
theologies sometimes and even wrong
Behavior
your body your mind your brain becomes
programmed and to fight against your
brain I was studying something called
neuroplasticity which points out your
brain will never take you any place
that's uncomfortable for it that's what
Paul mentions when he says I've fought a
good fight but early in his conversion
he says what I want to do that's what
I'm not doing what I don't want to do
that's what I'm practicing and Friends
remember practice makes permanent
doesn't make perfect so as you practice
being Christian the Bible says he who
practices righteousness is righteous
just as he that is God is righteous so
you have to keep in mind being a
Christian does come with a large dose of
self-denial as a matter of fact I think
that's the largest dose put aside what
you want to do and as Isaiah 1 vers 18
says cease to do evil verse 19 learn to
do good it is a practice you got to deny
yourself I want that don't have to get
that I want that Lord teach me what
denial is all about then John 12:25 and
26 six he who loves his life will lose
it and he who hates his life for in this
world will keep it for eternal life if
anyone serves me let him follow me and
where I am there my servant will be also
if anyone serves me him my father will
honor this is once again a a statement
of denial matter of fact John 21:18 when
Jesus confronted Peter notice what he
said he says most assuredly I say to you
when you were younger you GED yourself
and walked where you wished but when you
are old you will stretch out you will
stretch out your hands and another will
G you and carry you where you do not
wish that is that denial of self you got
to lay down yourself and say Lord I want
to do your will and here's the key what
does it profit a man if he gains the
whole world and loses his own soul
Matthew 16 and verse 26 so here it is
you got to make a decision do you want
to be the servant of Christ or the
servant of self if you want to be the
servant of Christ self-denial comes
first so true and in 1 John 3:7 it says
he who practices righteousness is
righteous just as he is righteous you
did a sermon called The Practice all the
practice you want to check that out on
YouTube Sermon called the practice thank
you for that okay let's move on okay
pastor Marone here we go in Genesis
1:2 it says the Earth was formless and
empty and darkness covered the Deep
Waters and the spirit of God was
hovering over the surface of the
water what was the spirit of God doing
this is from Margaret in Papa New
Guinea well that's a deep question that
you have there marget and um it's
interesting that it was formless so
there was disorganization we could say
that and then here comes the holy spirit
so what's he doing the word translated
in your Bible there hovering comes from
the Hebrew word rof and it's actually
used three times in the King James
version it means to brood or by
implication to be relaxed to move gently
to cherish and King James translated as
moved or rof upon the face of the waters
there's another place in Deuteronomy
chapter 32 uses the same Roff as an
eagle stirreth up her nest fluth or
rough over her Young spreadeth abroad
her wings taketh them beareth them on
her wings and then the third time it's
used there in the King James Jeremiah
23:9 Mine Heart Within Me is broken
because of the prophets all my bones
shake or
rof to shake to tremble that's the
meaning of that the main idea that we
get from this text is that the Holy
Spirit played an active role in
creation when I read your text Margaret
it sounds like you're wondering what
that looked like what that active role
was and you know here's a possibility
here you know God has allowed scientists
to discover that um this universe is
made up of
atoms so you know we look at there was
disorganization there so these atoms
actually consist there of a nucleus
which has one or more protons along with
neutrons and then there's an equal
number of electrons to the protons that
are moving around
this nucleus when I say moving that's
really an
understatement electrons travel in their
orbit around the
nucleus billions of times per second wow
it's
moving so when it says he was moving
whatever he's doing here with these I
Poss this is a possibility so besides
the motion inside the atom this is from
Harvard we know that at least four ways
that the atoms actually move the one's
called vibr ation so in solids atoms are
closely packed and primarily vibrate in
place around fixed positions so that's a
movement and then the second one is
translation in liquids and gases atoms
can move freely from one location to
another so I don't know if the holy
spirit's doing that moving atoms around
and then rotation is another one in some
cases especially in gas and liquids says
upon the face of the waters atoms or
molecules can rotate around their bonds
contributing to their overall motion and
then the fourth way that these atoms
move is defusion the atoms can move from
areas of higher concentration to areas
of lower concentration in the process
known as diusion this is particularly
significant in gases and liquids so I
don't like the possibility but thanks
for that question deep one amen thank
you well done and the Bible says we are
fearfully and wonderfully made amen
that's that's God is amazing amen made
from dust that's another statement yeah
yeah exactly thank you so much okay here
we go Daniel here's your
question can we prove that the weekly
cycle has remained the same since
creation I know that the Israelites had
a weekly manner where they observed the
Sabbath for 40 years by having to gather
twice the Mana on Friday so they had
food to eat on the Sabbath this is from
Raymond in North
Carolina all right this is a good
question how do we know that it's Monday
it's Monday for me right now I don't
know what day it is when you're watching
or listening to this well the day the
month and the year we understand by
looking at the movement of celestial
bodies all right the the the spinning of
the Earth the movement of the Earth
around the Sun the weekly exyle Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday and onward uh
we accept by faith and by the agree
agement of society and here's what I
mean when I say we accept it by faith
there's no point fixed point in nature
that I can look at to tell me oh it's
the seventh day just like I can look up
at the Sun and say ah it's noon right
now because of where the sun's at and so
I have to look in faith at the place
where the weekly cycle was originated
the only place and that's in the Book of
Genesis chapter 1 and two now here's
what I mean when I say that we have to
accept the weekly cycle based on the
agreement of society people have agreed
to keep track of the passage of time
together so we can speak intelligently
with one another when I say next Tuesday
we're all in agreement on that so how do
we know today's Monday well because
yesterday was Sunday and the day before
that was Sabbath and the and and we can
go back all the way because we're all in
agreement this pattern of keeping track
has continued back as far as people have
been keeping track of time marking it
together so is it possible that
somewhere a day or two could have been
added or lost or or or lost somewhere in
this there's only two ways that could
have happened way number one everyone in
the entire world wakes up on the same
day and has the same identical brain
malfunction on the entire globe and
every one of us on a Thursday wakes up
thinking it's Wednesday and none of us
know the wiser somehow a day got lost or
everybody in the entire world would have
to unite in a conspiracy y with no
dissension nobody wrote about it nobody
talked about it nobody kept a record
about it they all just had this devious
conspiracy to get rid of or at a day and
they all went silently to their graves
and none of us in the future ever found
out and add to that God would have to be
content to allow us to go on with this
error without giving us any correction
both of these options are so silly as to
be humorous we know from the Bible this
we know the day that was the sabath when
Jesus walked on this Earth Luke
23:56 Jesus died on the cross it says
and they rested on the Sabbath according
to the commandment and that lets us know
that at the time of Jesus death the word
confirms there had been no change that
had yet taken place that had cast any
doubt on God's holy day and since that
time there has arisen no chronological
uncertainty as to the days of the week
day one followed by day two 3 4 five
preparation day and then the Sabbath
that pattern of days has remained
completely unchanged historically even
in the 1500s when the Reckoning of the
dates the numbers changed it from the
Julian to the Gregorian calendars so yes
we can be confident that the days have
not changed wonderful thank you and the
Jewish Nation right yeah whole nation of
Jews they still keep the Sabbath the
seventh day Sabbath okay now if you are
just tuning in and you say hm this
program is really good and I have a
Bible question well you could email us
at bible
QA
3abn.org
person and you'd like to send a message
or a question in to us Instagram it it
is
3abn official so go ahead and send us a
question okay we'll be glad to answer
that for you all right thank you okay my
honey you ready I'm
ready here's your
question the biblical fact about
husbands and wives is that they are one
body M when it comes to washing of feet
during the Lord's Supper why doesn't the
husband wash the feet of his wife and
the wife washed the feet of her husband
this is from muamba they text it in to
us H well if you are a member of the
Thompsonville 7 Adventist Church we do
yes we we have we have Cycles we have
sometimes we just men washing men's feet
right a women washing women's feet and
then husbands washing the wi's feet and
the wife washing the husband foot and so
yes the Bible does not clarify that that
should not be done the example we give
of the washing of the feet was Jesus and
his disciples in John Chapter 13 but the
inference does not uh eliminate gender
here it is John
13:4 if I then your lord and teacher
have washed your feet you also ought to
wash one another's feet now we do not
recommend a boyfriend washing a
girlfriend's foot or a female church
member washing a male Church member's
foot or vice versa that is not uh a
covenant relationship like a husband and
a wife do husbands and wives have to
sometimes humble themselves what's the
answer honey absolutely okay there you
go that's right we have been married 41
years we know that to be a fact there
sometimes that Humanity gets the best of
us and the communion service is a
beautiful recet now we don't wait and
say well wait till communion we'll get
things better no we say you know honey
this is a good time to start over start
freshh let's just kind of put ourselves
side it's a Growing Experience a growing
relationship and the and the inference
in communion washing of one another's
feet is
this humbling yourselves showing that
you are more desirous to be a servant
than being served that's an act of
humility we call it the ordinance of
humility before the ordinance of the
Lord's supper and so James 4:10 humble
yourselves in the sight of the Lord and
He will lift you up now as a person who
has counseled couples since about 1989
there's some marriages that are just in
terrible Jeopardy because the pride of
one is greater than the love of the
other and they have just fought and they
don't want to give and some people don't
talk to each other for months and say
you know you you cook your own dinner
I'm not going to say anything to you
we're going to sleep in the same bed and
put a pillow between us that's just
ludicrous that is not a Christian
relationship and even if you're not a
Christian that's just not a marriage at
all so the act of humility is something
so beautiful Mark
9:35 speaking once again of the words of
Jesus and he sat down and called the
twel and said to them if anyone desires
to be
first he shall be last of all and
servant of all the communion service is
a beautiful time all my Ministry all of
our ministry for 37 years we've
implemented foot washing for male and
female only for husband and wife yes and
believe me I want to tell you as one
who's viewed that I've seen times when
they've shed tears privately as he said
honey I'm so sorry I've not been all
that I need to be would you forgive me
and they've washed one another's feet
and we have even washed the feet of
other people that we wanted to bring
their hearts into harmony with us and
with the Lord so yes if you're married
it's acceptable I believe as a pastor in
the sight of the Lord amen and it's a
beautiful thing we've done that and I
tell you it's it's a special moment and
we pray with each other and afterwards
as a group we have we all stand and
we'll say
together as husband and wives yeah as
husband and wife you know we do it
together and then as a group we pray
together also so it's special and you
bought this my husband bought this to
every Church we've gone to the husband
and wife uh foot washing and it's it is
very special it's not every communion
it's every what every other yeah we just
cycle it through come to Thompsonville
you'll enjoy it yeah thank you all right
Pastor Marone here's your question the
seventh day Sabbath existed before
creation did everyone rest on the
seventh day in the kingdom of God before
creation or was it specifically
Sanctified and blessed for humans at
creation to have a personal relationship
and connection with the
Creator I know it will be in important
in eternal life as well as it is is
written in Isaiah chapter 66
22-23 this is from ishan in Montreal
Quebec
Canada thank you for that question
Ison uh you seem to be a deep thinker
and that's great it causes us to have to
dig deeper into God's word for answers
to your questions you're correct in
referencing Isaiah 66 and let me read
this for our viewers for as the new
heaven heavens and the new Earth which I
will make shall remain before me sayeth
the Lord so shall your seed and your
name remain and it shall come to pass
that from one new moon to another and
from one Sabbath to another shall All
Flesh come to worship before me sayith
the Lord so from these verses we can see
that we will be worshiping God on the
Sabbath in the new heavens and earth
this will always remind us of God's
deliverance from our bondage of sin and
Satan while
it reminded the Israelites the same
thing it reminded the Israelites of
their deliverance from slavery that was
in Egypt and that was in Deuteronomy
512- to5 it mentions that it adds that
there's two places in Exodus and in
Deuteronomy about the Ten Commandments
and the fourth Commandment there so in
Exodus the version of the Sabbath
commandment reminds us that God is our
creator and then in the Deuteronomy
version it adds he's our deliverer so
those things will be reminded we'll be
reminded of those things God delivering
us and creating us throughout eternity
well as far as the seventh day Sabbath
existing in the past I'm not really sure
but in the creation account of the earth
it seems as though it may have begun
when God ended his work on the seventh
day and let's read that it's in Genesis
3 1 I mean 2 1:3 thus the heavens and
the Earth were finished and all the host
of them and on the seventh day God ended
his work which he had made and he rested
from all his work which he had made and
then God blessed the seventh day and
Sanctified it because that in it he had
rested from all his work which God
created and made so when the Bible
speaks of a
day it is speaking of our Earth's
rotation on its own axis you know it's
about 25,000 miles around the
circumference of this Earth and it's
going about a th000 miles an hour on its
own axis flying around there it's funny
why we don't fly fly off of here but it
takes about 24 hours to go around one
time so prior to the creation this Earth
the keeping of a Sabbath according to
the Reckoning from this planet's
perspective you know prior to that I'm
not sure what was done so if there's a
Sabbath being kept I'm not sure what it
was commemorating in other words if
there was a Sabbath being kept prior to
this Earth's creation I don't know how
it was related but we know that our
perspective is every seventh day is a
Sabbath so that question I don't really
know we'll have to ask the Lord did they
keep Sabbath before but thanks for the
question yes yes thank you all right
here is another interesting question and
a lot of young people H they they say
this okay this is a four minute question
for you Daniel is it okay to say oh my
God or OMG this is from Janette Janette
thank you for for this question you're
asking what maybe others have asked as
well and I'm going to start with Psalm
19:14 that says let the words of my
mouth and the meditations of my heart be
acceptable in your sight oh Lord my
strength and my redeemer the phrase oh
my God or something similar appears many
times in the Bible in an attitude of
reverent prayer but you're not referring
to that here you're referring to using
that phrase uh essentially as an
expletive where we throw out the
strongest words possible to indicate
strong feeling and emotion and
ultimately our world has reduced God's
name simply to a statement of surprise
like look what I just saw and so to
disguise this sin of taking God's name
in vain our world has given us some very
thinly veiled substitutes for oh my God
oh my God becomes OMG I just want you to
know I hate talking like this but these
things need to be understood oh my God
becomes oh my goodness I have no
goodness in myself God is goodness
that's right we then reduce that to just
goodness goodness gracious gracious me
good grief good gravy all of that is
coming from the same thing oh my God
turns into oh my yeah my my me oh my oh
man all these things coming from the
same direction oh my word oh my Lord or
just Lord lordy Lord good Lord maybe
you've said some of those yourself God
becomes gosh golly we call this veggie
swearing by God becomes bygum by George
we are not going to talk this way in
heaven and we would not say these things
if we were standing at the foot of the
cross Jesus is too special our father is
too special too holy to drag his name
through the mud the name of Jesus
becomes g g whiz g willikers g g
Shish Jesus Christ becomes Jiminy
Christmas Jiminy Cricket and these are
called minced Oaths wow think about the
Holiness of God and then we say holy cow
holy moly holy smokes holy mackerel holy
guacamole we think about God home in
heaven and then we say good Heavens
Heavens Heavens to Betsy and I could add
a whole bunch more probably where we
swear too lightly I swear to God I swear
on a stack of Bibles God is my witness
and maybe you could add more where it's
all in the character
of stepping on some people's toes
because you had not thought of these
things before but it's worth thinking
about why we do what we do all of these
things come from the same root of taking
God's name in vain even if we're doing
it
unintentionally instead of taking the
hard work to really think about what do
I mean in my heart and how can I express
that in a way that's true we sometimes
unwittingly trample upon the Holiness of
God because we've been trained by the
patterns of this world and so
meaningless Expressions come out of our
mouth because they're revealing honestly
an emptiness it's in our own hearts and
Minds everything we speak should be true
and should be useful for building up and
if we don't have something nice to say
don't say anything at all especially
about God's name so let me close with
Ecclesiastes 5:2 go back and listen to
some of those phrases I use and say Lord
help me help me not to use those do not
be rash with your mouth and let not your
heart utter anything Hasty before God
for God is in heaven and you on Earth
therefore let your Words Be Few that's
Ecclesiastes 5:2 yes wow wow Beau that
was powerful and I'm too have been
guilty of that with the OMG too yes but
oh my goodness I've done that too so we
got to be careful how we use these
derivatives of God's name got to be
careful thank you Daniel did great job
with that okay here's your 4minute
question honey yes when this is a good
one when we die do we immediately go to
heaven or hell or are we quote unquote
sleeping in our Graves until the final
Judgment Day when we will rise and enter
Heaven or Hell can you point to any
Scripture that explains this this is
from Tim yes thank you so much Tim
before I go any further I just want to
say that was a master class Daniel in
four minutes of all the things that we
say that are taken God's name and the
Bible says let your yes be yes and your
no be no anything outside of that
Matthew 5:37 says is from the evil one
that's right thank you for that I boy
that took me through the decades thank
you for that anyway right to your
question uh yes when we die we do not
immediately go to heaven as a matter of
fact when if you've been to a funeral
I'm sure you have you go to the Grave if
you've been to a memorial service the
person's remains are in and earn and the
Bible makes it very clear from the very
creation of humanity you know Genesis
21:17 the Bible says then the Lord God
formed man from The Genesis 2:7 the Lord
God formed man from the dust of the
ground and breathed into his nostrils
the breath of life and Man became a
living being or some translation says
living Soul so there's this ideology
this this it's called neop platonistic
Uh theology there's this belief that
there's a soul hanging out on your body
and when you die it just leaves and
decides well where should I go let me go
to Brooklyn I need another body that's
that's just total paganistic beliefs
there's no soul hanging out in US Man
became a living Soul when they were
created the Breath of God plus the dust
of the ground combined together Man
became a living Soul so what happens
when a person dies here's what the Lord
warned Adam right on the heels of being
evicted from the Garden of Eden because
of his choice to sin Genesis 3:19 in the
sweat of your face you shall eat bread
get this till you return
to the ground for out of it you were
taken for dust you are and to dust you
shall return those are powerful words
because here's the point if you came
from Heaven that's where you go back
to but you didn't come from Heaven you
came from the dust and the Lord himself
says for dust you are and to dust you
will return Psalm
115:17 the dead do not praise the Lord
nor any who go down into silence
not up into praise vitally important
because this world has spun so many
lives through movies ghosts Halloween uh
the media pastors they use scriptures
like to be to be absent from the body is
to be present with the Lord that's not
about death at all Paul the Apostle was
referring to the problems the trials he
says in this body We Grown yearning to
be set free yearning to be delivered and
then the very same Apostle Paul talks
about how that freedom happens for the
Lord himself will descend from heaven
with a shout with the voice of the
Archangel with the trumpet of God and
the dead in Christ will be rise first
that's 1 Thessalonians chap 4: uh 13
to18 then he says in 1 Corinthians 15:
51-55 for this
Mortal that is those who die must put on
immortality this corruptible the
decaying body will put on incorruption
but notice what he says when that
happens then the change comes
you see we will not all sleep that is
die but we will all be changed no one
goes to heaven prior to the change when
does the change happen at the last
trumpet for the trumpet will sound and
the dead will be raised Incorruptible
and we shall be changed so what happens
until that time John 5: 28 and 29 do not
Marvel at this for the hour is coming in
which all who are in the graves will
hear his voice and come forth those who
have done good to the resurrection of
Life those who have done evil to the
resurrection of condemnation that's what
happened two resurrections whatever
Resurrection you're in determines your
destiny resurrection of life that we
Ascend to meet the Lord in the a that's
what 1 Thessalonians 4 talks about for
John chapter 14 I will come again to
receive you so here's the way I end it
Ecclesiastes 9:10 whatever your hands
find to do do it with your might for
there is no work or device or knowledge
all wisdom in the grave here it is where
you are going amen but some people will
say oh the soul the soul that sinth you
will die it will die and that's exactly
clear the soul is not Immortal that's a
neopl neop platonistic paganistic view
there's nothing Immortal about us only
God has immortality amen 1 Timothy I
think is 1 verse 16 only God is
immortality not Humanity thank you for
that answer all from the word of God
Amen okay Daniel Marone here's your
question in Exodus Moses was given
instructions for anointing oil but God
said that this was a holy oil and not to
make it not to make any like it not to
put it on flesh nor to put it on a
stranger or they will be cut off from
their people in Matthew Jesus talks
about anointing your head with oil when
you fast in Mark and James the disciples
talk about anointing the sick with oil
is anointing okay if so is there a
specific anointing oil that should or
should not be used there are so many
things about anointing your home your
family the sick
Etc out in this world so many anointing
um things that people say that's out in
this world I want to ensure I follow the
word of God this is from Lisa and she
wants to know is it okay to use
anointing
oil well thank you Lisa for that
question and I commend you for your
commitment to following God's word you
know the this recipe for the anointing
oil that was found here in Exodus was a
sacred recipe that would bring the O
Factory nerves into the sensing of the
sacredness of God's sanctuary and
everything connected with it by keeping
this scent exclusive to the sanctuary
every time they smelled it they were
reminded that God is Holy and his house
and Priests Are Holy so when we see hear
touch or taste something that sensory
information first heads to the thalamus
which acts as your brain's relay station
the thalamus then sends the information
to relevant brain areas including the
hippocampus which is responsible for
your memory and the amydala which is
responsible for your emotional
processing but with smells it's
different these scents P bypass the
thalamus and they go straight to the
brain smell Center known as the
olfactory bulb and if you see that in a
anatomy of the brain the olfactory bulb
is directly connected to the amygdala
and the hippocampus which might explain
why the smell of something can so
immediately trigger detailed memory even
intense emotion you remember smelling
Grandma's pie and Thanksgiving whatever
you bring brings back all those memories
but we can we have several references in
the New Testament about anointing it and
but none give a recipe or a formula for
the anointing oil to be used but most
likely it was from the oil of the olive
which was due to its availability the
oil is a representation of the Holy
Spirit 1st Samuel 16:13 then Samuel took
the Horn of oil and anointed him in the
midst of his Brethren and the spirit of
the Lord Came Upon David from that day
forward and so Samuel arose and went to
rain
we have another reference in Zechariah
4:6 where the Prophet Zechariah sees in
Vision a Candlestick being fed with oil
from two olive trees the angel asks him
if he knows what he's seeing and
Zechariah says no he doesn't then this
is what the angel says in verse 6 this
is the word of the Lord unto Z saying
not by might nor by power but by my
spirit sayith the Lord of hosts again
thank you for your question bless it
amen thank you for that okay Daniel
let's go right to it
Luke Chapter uh 22:3 states that Satan
entered Judas how did he do that this is
from Frank in California thank you Frank
for your question Satan entered Judas
with judas's permission there you go it
was judas's thoughts and actions that
finally gave full permission for Satan
to direct and guide his thoughts and
actions Jesus had also been inviting
through his three and a half years of
Ministry but Judas had put himself in
the habit of resisting Jesus invitations
even though he had been um in Jesus
presence and working in Ministry
empowered by Jesus to cast out demons to
preach and to teach and so this this is
all seen in one event that immediately
precipitates Judas going out to betray
Jesus John 12 tells us that uh Mary
Magdalene pours out this perfume on
jesus' feet and Judas is upset by that
and it tells us there that uh he didn't
he wasn't upset because he cared for the
poor but because he was a thief and had
the money box and he used to take what
was put into it Judas Witnesses Jesus
love for this woman and his pride rises
in him the pride that that he had
allowed Satan to to to kind of nourish
him and marinate in and so then there
comes a moment of finality when after
all these little decisions come and go
when you place yourself fully under the
direction and gu of Satan and this
happens after Judas had already betrayed
Jesus or agreed to betray Jesus Jesus is
still inviting him longing for his
conversion and Jesus gets down on his
knees in front of Judas and washes his
feet an invitation to Judas yes but
judah's heart now was so filled with
Satan's principles of Pride and
self-exaltation that he chose to reject
this invitation and Satan was completely
invited in could this happen to you
could this happen to me yes we can do
the same thing and it doesn't matter at
what stage we are in life small
decisions build up one after another
until we make a pivotal decision that
says I want the principles of Pride and
selfishness those are the principles of
Satan to guide my life and they have
full permission so every decision that
we make matters and this is why Paul
writes in Ephesians 427 that we should
not give place to the devil not even a
little bit even a small decision that's
what happened with Judas wow you don't
want that to happen to you we're going
to take a short break and we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at at bible QA
[Music]
3abn.org whenever we go to the panel and
read from the word of God well we're
going to give our panel a few closing
thoughts just a few seconds so let's
start with you honey you know I would
say keep studying God's word and the
things that are mysterious When you pray
and ask for the spirit's guidance will
be become abundantly clear yes okay
pastor Marone again thank you so much
for those questions that you sent in it
helped us to dig deeply into God's word
We Appreciate You Yes Daniel Psalm 111
verse 9 says holy and awesome is his
name referring to God and if if uh if
you've been taking God's name and
bringing it down ask God to help you
lift it up amen wow thank you so much
you guys wonderful wonderful I'm going
to leave you with a Bible verse Thy word
I have hid within my heart that I might
not sin against you that is from Psalm
119:1 keep trus in the Lord he's coming
soon and we will be going home to our
Eternal Place God bless you
[Music]